[Musique]
vous aimez travailler en groupe en
équipe
c'est génial non moi je trouve ça génial
bah oui parce que chacun vient avec ses
idées ces énergies son énergie son
engagement ses compétences
et puis en fait ensemble on arrive à
faire des choses qu'on peut pas faire
seul c'est ça un groupe c'est génial
il y a même un dicton africain qui dit
seul on va plus vite mais ensemble on va
plus loin
c'est génial de travailler en équipe non
non
bon ok
on est entre nous on peut se parler là
en fait c'est super compliqué de
travailler en équipe on est d'accord
bah ouais parce que on est tellement
différent on est tellement différent on
veut pas les mêmes choses on n'a pas les
mêmes convictions on n'a pas les mêmes
idées on est tellement différent
pas les mêmes vécu non plus et on arrive
avec tout ça
du coup c'est c'est super compliqué de
travailler en équipe en groupe
et en fait la norme dans un groupe dans
une équipe c'est pas de que tout soit
fluide en fait que ça se passe bien que
ce soit harmonieux non mais ça ça
n'existe pas c'est une utopie en fait ce
qui est normal dans un groupe parce
qu'on est tellement différent
c'est que on s'entende pas c'est qu'on
soit pas d'accord c'est qu'il y ait des
conflits c'est ça qui est normal dans un
groupe
je vous dis ça à la main
personne ne m'a dit ça à moi personne
m'a dit écoute Sandra tu vas travailler
dans des équipes les gens sont super
mais bon souvent vous allez quand même
pas être d'accord et vous allez avoir à
gérer des conflits mais t'inquiète pas
on va te préparer
en fait on nous prépare pas à ça on nous
dit pas ça que c'est ça la réalité d'un
groupe on nous le dit pas
d'ailleurs
en fait on nous dit on nous dit même que
le conflit c'est c'est mal
que c'est un problème
d'ailleurs depuis qu'on est tout petit
on nous dit ça regardez je prends
l'exemple d'un
deux enfants qui veulent jouer avec le
même jouet classique
il se dispute qu'est-ce qui se passe
en fait la première chose qui se passe
c'est qu'il y a des adultes qui arrivent
les parents en général et qui disent hop
hop oh là là
tout va bien calmez-vous on va trouver
une solution et puis vous allez alors
toi tu vas commencer par jouer cinq
minutes avec avec ça et puis et puis toi
à 5 minutes après et puis vous allez on
va partager ça va le faire
c'est ça qu'on nous dit du coup on
comprend que c'est pas ok en fait de pas
être d'accord
personne vient nous dire
écoutez les enfants c'est super en fait
vous êtes pas d'accord et vous savez
quoi dans la vie ça va vous arriver très
souvent donc c'est l'occasion de vous
appreniez à travailler sur vos
différences et vos désaccords
et donc bah je vais peut-être vous aider
mais vous allez trouver une solution
ensemble vous allez apprendre en fait
maintenant personne nous dit ça
en fait on nous dit que le conflit c'est
mal c'est un problème c'est même un
tabou
moi mon métier c'est justement d'aider à
dépasser les conflits dépasser les
désaccords et j'interviens beaucoup en
entreprise
et quand je discute avec un dirigeant je
lui dis comment ça se passe comment ça
se passe chez vous comment vous gérez
vos conflits
en général il me dit non mais non mais
chez nous ça va il y a pas de conflit
non non
ça ça n'existe pas mais c'est tabou en
fait le conflit c'est vu comme un échec
on n'a pas réussi à travailler ensemble
donc on vient conflit
alors c'est tellement vu comme un échec
que on finit par fuir les conflits en
fait on évite absolument tous les sujets
de désaccord
ah bah non je vais quand même pas dire
ça parce que c'est sûr elle va se
braquer
c'est ça qui se passe en fait
la plupart du temps
et du coup
fini par se passer et il finit par se
passer que en fait je parce que je fuis
le conflit je dis oui alors que je pense
non
au fond j'y crois pas du tout à cette
idée je vois même pas le sens que ça
mais bon comme c'est tellement compliqué
là de
dire que je suis pas d'accord je finis
par dire oui
et souvent qu'est-ce qui se passe
derrière
je suis frustré
en fait je lui en veux d'amener cette
idée en fait je m'en veux d'avoir dit
oui alors que je pensais non
et ça aide pas beaucoup à la
collaboration ça
sauf que en fait moi j'ai décidé
d'accompagner les conflits parce que je
vois que
un conflit c'est juste une façon
d'apprendre à coopérer
mais vraiment coopérer c'est à dire pas
penser qu'on va se retrouver sur des
points communs qu'on va être d'accord
c'est partir de la réalité c'est à dire
de nos différences de nos désaccords de
nos divergences
qu'en fait c'est ça le chemin
parce que c'est ça à la richesse d'un
groupe la richesse d'un groupe c'est pas
les points communs c'est les différences
c'est quand on croise nos regards
différents qu'en fait on est plus
intelligent ensemble c'est ça la
richesse d'un groupe mais pour ça il
faut qu'on apprenne à gérer nos
différences
et aller faire dialoguer
en fait le conflit c'est le chemin vers
la coopération c'est ça
bon alors vous allez peut-être me dire
ok mais je le vois pas très bien moi le
chemin entre le conflit là l'opposition
bien dure et la coopération c'est pas
évident là
alors
j'ai envie juste de vous donner quatre
éléments clés quatre points que moi je
vois et qui fonctionne pour dépasser un
conflit
la première celle qui aide c'est celle
que je viens de vous partager
c'est en fait d'accepter que le conflit
est normal et que c'est pas un problème
et que il faut y aller faut écouter faut
regarder faut explorer
et qu'en fait on peut en apprendre des
choses
ça ça aide beaucoup ça donne beaucoup
plus envie
d'aller au contact de l'autre et d'aller
échanger
le deuxième c'est
oser parler de vous
[Musique]
osez parler de vous de ce qui est
important pour vous
de ce à quoi vous tenez de ce à quoi
pourquoi vous vous battez qui fait que
vous êtes en conflit parler aussi de vos
ressentis
alors en général quand je dis ça
à des gens qui sont en conflit ils me
disent oh là mais moi j'ai pas tellement
envie en fait parce que je me dis que
si je parle de moi je me dévoile
du coup je donne du pouvoir à l'autre là
pour
pour m'attaquer en fait si je parle de
moi de mes ressentis de ce qui compte
pour moi avec mon cœur mes tripes en
fait je suis pas puissant là je suis
vulnérable je suis faible
je pense que une conférence t'aide c'est
justement
finalement l'occasion de vivre tout le
contraire qu'est-ce que c'est c'est des
gens qui viennent avec leur cœur leur
tripes et qui vous parle de sujets qui
sont importants pour eux
et je peux vous dire quand on est là
qu'on se sent pas vulnérable on sent
puissant on est aligné on a envie
donc il faut lutter contre une croyance
autour de ça on est on est là ce soir
pour aller derrière les croyances
non parler de ses émotions parler de ce
qui compte pour toi c'est pas être
vulnérable cette puissance
donc deuxième conseil oser parler de
vous de ce qui compte pour vous
troisième conseil
écoutez l'autre mais écoutez le vraiment
et ne le voyez pas comme une caricature
en fait de ce qu'il est ne le réduisez
pas à ses comportements à ce qu'il vous
a dit à ce qu'il a fait oui il est ça
et peut-être que parfois c'est
répréhensible et que il y a pas à
tolérer tous les comportements mais ne
le réduisez pas à ça
souvent moi j'entends mais cette
personne elle est toxique lui il est
bête on peut pas travailler avec lui on
peut pas travailler avec elle on va
jamais y arriver
regardez l'autre comme ça c'est le
meilleur moyen en fait de s'engueuler
dans le conflit
l'autre est bien plus que ça
bien plus que ça
troisième conseil écoutez vraiment
l'autre
il regarde les le dans son humanité
et dernier conseil parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut bien trouver des solutions
quand on est dans un conflit il faut
trouver des accords quoi
dernier conseil
accepter de changer de regard et de
chercher comment on peut faire du et
plutôt que du ou passer du et au ou le
ou c'est quoi c'est c'est lui au moins
c'est gagnant perdant
en fait si vous ouvrez le champ des
possibles c'est possible de faire lui et
moi
de faire gagner en gagnant
mais il faut un petit peu changer de
regard alors vous allez me dire
ok mais si on veut le même poste le même
rôle comment on fait il y en a bien
qu'un seul on peut pas faire du et
bah si c'est possible
si vous voulez ce rôle ce poste dans ce
groupe
ça vous permet quoi c'est pour c'est
pour faire quoi au fond qu'est-ce qui
compte pour vous vous voulez peut-être
plus de liberté plus d'autonomie plus de
sens
qu'est-ce que vous voulez au fond
qu'est-ce qui va vous apporter ce rôle
là c'est ça la question et si vous
remontez à cet endroit là aux endroits
des enjeux profondes vos aspirations
profondes en fait vous vous rendez
compte que le champ des possibles est
vaste que là vous êtes en train de vous
fixer sur ce poste là et peut-être c'est
ça que vous allez faire mais qu'en fait
il y a plein de solutions qui permettent
que
vos besoins soient satisfaits mais aussi
que l'autre trouve son compte en fait le
champ des possibles est vaste
le conflit c'est pas un échec
c'est le chemin pour apprendre à faire
dialoguer nos différences
donc n'ayez pas peur du conflit
oser
écouter l'autre parler de vous de ce qui
compte pour vous et trouver des
solutions
qui vous permettent de chacun soit
satisfait il y a un chemin
alors pourquoi je vous parle de ça moi
ce soir pourquoi ça me paraît si
important
au-delà de mon métier de ce que je fais
je suis avant tout une citoyenne comme
vous
et comme vous je vois les défis qui sont
les nôtres
et on va en parler ce soir
j'ai pas de solution moi mais par contre
j'ai une conviction
c'est qu'on y arrivera pas si on
s'oppose les uns aux autres
on y arrivera pas si on se caricature
les uns les autres
nous avons besoin de combiner nos forces
nos idées et nos compétences nous avons
besoin de dépasser nos divergences nos
conflits pour trouver des solutions
et combiner nos expertises ensemble en
fait c'est ça dont on a besoin
et on en a tellement besoin parce que on
n'a pas les solutions encore
donc nous avons besoin de coopération
plus que jamais
c'est ça que je suis venu vous dire ce
soir en fait
alors
s'il vous plaît
osez aborder les sujets qui fâchent avec
vos amis dans vos familles dans vos
équipes
oser explorer vos désaccords parce que
c'est comme ça que vous allez apprendre
à coopérer les uns avec les autres
à combiner vos différences
et ce sera là la richesse
et nous en avons tellement besoin
s'il vous plaît
osez